[Musique]
les dernières heures d'une histoire
d'amour de l'énigmatique henry pic
évitables trion littéraire madeleine big
je pose la question tout haut que
beaucoup de gens se posent tout bas
êtes-vous certaine que c'est bien votre
mari qui est écrit ce roman est en train
de vous moquer de mon mari dans les vous
l'imaginez le pizzaïolo breton qui
pointent à buca de cette envergure est
sérieusement tu vois pas pas écrire ça
entre deux feux de peter j'ignore qui a
écrit ce livre et je vais trouver
vous prenez pour qui vous avez le culot
de venir ici mais ça va pas bien vous
pourquoi henry pic
pourquoi toute cette mystification j'ai
besoin de vous pour aller au bout de
cette enquête
vous êtes un peu mon docteur watson
pourquoi c'est mon cerveau comme ça
parce que c'est mon enquête
si on pouvait trouver une lettre j'en ai
des lettres de lui ouais c'est pas
exactement ce dont je me souvenais
peut-être que ses retombées sur la liste
de courses de proust bruit mais on a
retrouvé la liste des courses de proue
ce dessin de la gueule regardez on
réplique emporté son secret dans la
tombe
acceptez-le vous allez arrêter d'en
garder ma fille avait quand même pas
nous menacer avec votre binette
non ça c'est une certitude
j'ai presque tout perdu avec ce bouquin
mais est en train de bouleverser nos
vies c'est ce livre qui bouleverse nos
vies ne pensais pas je vais fine
vous savez où il habite elle va alors
ils habitent ou qui la guette la
dernière maison lacroix tenue ou
infirmières il ya un problème là